[Music]
my closest friends in high school the
kids I ate lunch with included a Cuban
Jew a South Indian Hindu a Nigerian
evangelical a Mormon a Lutheran a
Catholic and we talked about everything
under the Sun as sixteen-year-old
suburban high school kids are want to do
we never talked about religion and even
though there were parts of all of our
lives that were at least a little bit
religious it generally manifested in
something along the lines of I can't
play basketball this Sunday because my
mom's making me go to some to some
religion thing but our families had a
certain set of expectations around our
religious participation and some people
especially my my latter-day saints
friend was especially involved in this
and that kind of stuff so so why does it
matter that religion was was not part of
the conversation for a couple of months
during my high school career a group of
thugs in my school started going after
my Jewish friend and they would call him
ugly anti-semitic slurs in the hallway
and they would scroll really terrible
things on classroom desks and I saw my
once-vibrant
friend like slink into the shadows of
the school he would come to school right
as the opening bell rang he would leave
right as the closing bell rang and I
watched this happen over these couple
months few years later when we were home
from college for a summer he brings this
up with me and he says you know those
were the worst months of my life and the
part of it that really sucked wasn't
what those thugs did to me it was
watching you watch me suffer and do
nothing why'd you do nothing and you
know I'm 43 years old and I've done a
lot of dumb things and that's the most
humiliating moment of my life is my
friend calling me out on a moment of
like profound weakness right like of the
opposite of courage right and I told the
story to my dad who is not a ritualistic
Muslim at all
but he was like you failed your friend
and you failed your faith like what do
you mean I failed my faith he's like
we're Muslims EBU we stand up for people
who are hurting that's the core of the
religion that's what it means to be
remodeled al-amin a mercy upon all the
worlds as Allah says to the Prophet
Muhammad in the holy quran right and
that's when i started to think to myself
why is it that my friend group wasn't
talking about religion but these thugs
in my school were happy to be openly
anti-semitic it's one of the early
experiences in my life that got me
thinking about how important it is to be
positive and proactive about engaging
religious identity towards interfaith
cooperation and that is now a norm in
american life right like your elementary
school where you send your kids the
hospital where your kids were born right
those are all religiously diverse places
and that religious diversity matters I
mean let's think for a moment about how
religious diversity intersects with
health care different religious
orientations literally have different
definitions of when life begins have
different definitions of what to do when
a baby is born have different
definitions of what a good life is and
have different definitions of when a
person dies so if you are a nurse or a
doctor and you enter the room of a
Buddhist family who whose grandfather is
on the bed about to pass into the next
world and you point to the brain scan
and say we're very sorry that grandpa
has has passed and the family looks at
you and says grandpa still hooked up to
the breathing machine and still has
breath he's not dead those Buddhists
have a different definition of death
than Western science that doesn't mean
you have to agree with their definition
but if you're a doctor you better not
handle that situation and there are four
million Buddhists in America there are
four million ELCA Christians in
America 2 million Episcopalian 6 billion
Methodists what I mean to say is that
religious minority communities are
growing there's about 4 million Muslims
in America for example a couple million
Hindus increasingly our educational our
health care facilities our athletic
leagues our businesses are going to be
religiously diverse and part of what
every educated American needs is the
ability to positively engage that
religious diversity
[Music]